透視K棒
K棒就是每一天多空在作戰
如果只看今天的這根K線
就知道多空哪個牆
紅的…
這個小心
明天要是疊就會下來
這個都是紅的 對
所以我講你這不要賣
明天還有高點89成都會上來
長這樣就要留意了
只要你這個影線太長了
都小心一點
那這些如果
不要擔心
它是個訊號 對
你叫注意第二天的開啟
你回去找一百張圖你就相信
八九不離十都是
就下去
注意囉
這三個
三個會長的可以放圖盒
把我們可以低點評審手好
對
然後你再來喔
哇 賺錢了
哎唷
宋老師 我很好奇你的生活
我的生活很單調耶
很單調嗎
對啊 多單調
沒有像年輕人這麼多彩多字
你最近有沒有去玩
去花蓮 台南 屏東
沒有 沒那個時間
我大概都是
我是軍人退伍的嘛
所以生活非常規律
我到現在也是大概六點起床
會摺豆腐乾嗎
那個大概不會
你還知道有個豆腐乾
透露年齡
好 整理一下
我有時候忙六點半
會七點就要進工作室
因為我要把整個的國際盤
都要看一下
還要準備一下
早上開盤的一些東西
因為我教學生
也做很多的功課
開盤前要做一些什麼功課
那我自己也要做
對 我們下次有一集來講
你老師怎麼做功課
開盤前要做一些
很重要的準備
如果今天知道說
有好機會 今天會大漲
那你要把握好
今天就容易賺錢
所以我覺得很奇妙的一點
今天理財大人秀的
標股在線等
剛剛朱老師在聊天的過程
告訴我們
他其實盤錢會做很多的準備
因為老師告訴我們
買股票要怎麼樣
收盤錢再買
但是開盤錢
你要做非常多的功課
我們會來用一集的時間
告訴你怎麼做功課
但是今天這集非常重要
我們都說老師是什麼
老師是K線之神
但是K棒我們還沒有講
所以今天的標股在線等第五集
我們要來透視K棒
非常寶貴的一堂課
因為好多人都講說
朱老師講的他們才聽得懂
朱老師講的是
現在全部市場上講得最清楚的
不管KD啦
MSED啦 軍線
東尼講得最棒
謝謝
所以K棒
朱老師
一定要更棒
我們前面有一個標竿
叫全陣小哥
他有一集K棒講得很好
但是我相信朱老師
一定有你更獨到的地方
這個K棒是技術分析之母
技術分析之母
對 沒有K棒什麼都沒了
軍線啊 這些都沒有了
都沒了
對 對
所以我們今天這一集
對KBUN是很重要的認識
因為你懂了KBUN
你就會知道它的變化
是 對
那我們大家很多
很多同學都是希望早點買 早點賣
對不對
那你在憑什麼去找買
憑什麼去找賣
就是憑KBUN
我們來看一下喔
因為趙華也是做理財達人秀之後
才學會看KBUN
之前軍線什麼都有看
所以有時候
像之前我常會有一個疑惑
同樣喔 是一個K版
而且留下一個常常的上影線
對 盤中有一個高價嘛
手排沒那麼高了
當然不是很喜歡
但是後續卻是上漲
對 而且它是一個黑K耶
然後這邊卻相反囉
也是留一個常常上影線
後來就下去 後面卻是疊下去
這個真看不懂耶 說真的
好 我們今天就是要討論這個
今天這個節目
大概看完了你就懂了
就懂了 對
我們就來討論
其實K-Bung就是每一天
假設我們是看日線
K-Bung就是每一天多空在作戰
作戰
當然 有人買有賣嘛 對不對
那就看哪個厲害
誰贏
對 是賣的人厲害
還是買的人兇
買的人多
那可能這個就會拉出一個紅棒
那賣的人多就是一個黑棒
所以我們第一個基本認識
先認識什麼叫紅什麼叫黑嘛
對不對
那紅就是多方的力量比較強
是 買盤比較旺
買盤比較積極
他要用外盤架去追
所以就會把股價越追越高
那KK就是大家急著賣
所以都降價賣
所以在類盤架去成交
所以那個股價就一直跌
最後收成一個黑的
這是K線的基本認識
基本原理就是多空兩方日交站
KK空方站上風
空K就是多方站上風
好 那我們在這裡先告訴大家
你為什麼要把K棒
不但要學會還要學得很精
學會要學精 要學通
對 因為K棒
第一個 當天就可以知道
哪個牆了
如果你把它分析好的話
那第二個 K棒是一個轉折位置
所以大家有講說
希望買在第一根
那就要去抓轉折
轉折點的K棒
賣在第一根就也是K棒
那第三個 K棒的反應最快
對
因為KBANG每天都在反應市場上
所有的東西
因為我們都知道這個股票交易的背後
很複雜嘛
有政治面 有經濟面
有消息面 各種各種
那最後會匯集到就這個KBANG
成為那個圖形 對
它就會出來這個圖形
昨天一個長紅
你就會看第二天就長黑
好奇怪喔 對不對
為什麼 那就是在反應市場
對這支股票的看法
昨天還看好 今天就看壞
OK 好
金通K棒容易相對低點跟相對高點
這也就是我們為什麼要金通
各位 我們在股票市場都講
都希望買在低點賣在高點
都是這麼說 順口溜
哪裡是低點 哪裡是高點
那就在K棒
我以前有一個朋友很有意思
他因為要上課
晚上都要從龍潭趕來
後來他媽媽說你這麼忙
晚上要去上課
他說對啊 我要去學股票
他們說股票有什麼好學的
就低買高賣就好啦
你低點買高就賣
豪耳熟的一句
就賺錢啦
選舉就是選票多的會
但問題是哪邊是低
哪邊是高
就要看K棒囉
朱老師我們都要從最基礎交期
一根K棒到底它代表什麼意涵
沒錯
我們來複習一下
K棒怎麼形成的
怎麼形成的
假設我們今天早上9點開盤
好 9點開盤囉
下午1點半收盤
100塊開盤
那收盤103塊5毛
那這中間就是多空嘛
多空交戰
盤中曾經
盤中有一個最低點
對 跌到98
這裡有個最高點
漲到107
那現在收盤要畫K線
對
我們就把開盤價拉一條線
收盤價103.5
對
最高點最低點
那開盤跟收盤是不是有價差
有
那它有價差我們就畫10體棒
所以這個叫實體棒
那最高最低
我們畫一條垂直線
那這個露出來的叫隱線
下面叫下隱線
那為什麼叫紅的
因為今天開盤比較低
收盤比較高
收盤比開盤高 價位高
收得漂亮
所以它是紅的
這是紅的
但是最高價的話
我們要畫一條上隱線
最低價要畫一條下隱線
那也就是我們每天看到的K線
都有這四個東西
都有開盤收盤最高最低
所以這四個叫做K線的四大元素
四大元素
當然這是發明K線人定義的
是 他發明的嘛
所以他是這樣去定義的
就是開低收高的紅K棒
像這個樣子
那反過來
也是一樣
他開的比較高
收的比較低
然後也是最高最低
那這個叫黑K
他開盤價比較高
收盤價比較低
這叫黑K
那黑黑就代表為什麼開盤103
為什麼收盤變100
那就是賣的人比較兇嘛
對不對
所以賣方比較強
那這個買方一直撐不住他
就一直往後退
那最後收盤收在下面
所以這叫黑的
這個就會黑黑的形成
所以紅跟黑是牽涉到
開盤加和收盤加對不對
他就是以開盤跟收盤來做比較
是 好那這四大元素呢
我們要怎麼樣來觀察
四個下格誰最重要
那也就是說
為什麼要用這四個來畫K線
為什麼不用別的
所以這四個一定有它的意義
所以你把這四個弄清楚
每天在K線你就看懂了
我們先看開盤
我先問問趙華開盤是誰開的
開盤是誰開的 一定是你開的
你買的 我買第一盤的人開的
你買第一盤的人開的
不對
不是我啊 不是你開的
開盤是主力開的
主力為什麼能開 我不能開
主力因為你的那個數量太少
如果你開盤掛一個漲停板的話
他賣給你就不會漲停板
開盤你的學生開的不是我
不是主力開的
好 主力開的
因為我們在股票市場
有幾個很重要的概念
股價是主力決定的
所以等於開盤價
跟主力很有關係囉
所以當天的變盤關鍵
就在開盤價
剛才我們講看到上面有上影線
明天要小心喔 要跌囉
那會不會跌
你就去看開盤價 好
開低大概就會下來了 好
那盤中的最高價是什麼意思
就是多
我們講多空交站嘛 對
最高價就是多方公道的最高位置
然後就上不去了
這個最高價啊
我常有困擾
我常常看他漲
我受不了了 我去買
我就是變成那個最高價耶
常這樣耶
因為你就買在高點啦
太厲害了 我覺得散戶這一點
太厲害了 你知道嗎
用你在盤中去買
對 然後都
怎麼是我在那邊插旗子
其實如果我們有講
如果你在盤中要進場
你就不能看日線
你要看五分K
你五分K買在高檔
我沒有聽你的話
我要收盤錢再去買
你五分K買在高檔
好 那最高價就是
空方抵擋的位置
也就是你多方上不去囉
所以這個叫壓力
所以最高價是來測壓力的
最高價是測壓力的
因為上不去 多方測壓
那如果沒有壓就供到漲停板
沒有壓嘛 我就一直漲
對不對 那就是測壓
那最低價就測支撐了
反過來嘛 跌不下去了
盤中有多跟空嘛
空方就一直打打打不下去啦
那就要有支撐
所以最低價是來測支撐的
所以我們等一下看便板
現在有個長下影線
那就代表支撐很強
因為我來撤
結果被拉回來了
所以下影線留這麼長
對 那就是低檔有支撐
那收藩家就更重要了
因為結束了
今天也告一段落
換句話講
今天的多空作戰結束了
那結束就要看誰厲害了
今天誰強 結算了
所以收藩家就是看
今天多空的強弱的
所以這一張
我們講起來四個都各有重要的位置
所以四個都要把它弄懂
那這個就是收盤架
我們來看一下
這個是收 我們剛剛有講紅K嘛
開低走高
收盤比開盤高
收盤在這喔
所以你看到今天收盤的
上面就是空方的
下面就是多方的
這一段都是做多的力道
所以你一看就知道今天多方起來
因為多方比較長嘛
那這個反過來
收盤在這裡
三分之二都空放的
對 這個就是收盤比開盤弱囉
對 今天多方只有拉到這個地方
沒有辦法拉到上面
所以今天的空放比較強
那如果說在中間
今天多空平分
好 勢均力敵
我們如果只看今天的這根K線
你就知道多空哪個強了
用收盤看嘛 沒錯
然後你為什麼要看呢
你就可以跟昨天比了
今天的K棒要跟昨天的K棒比
就是看有沒有變化了
如果昨天是長紅多方強
那今天呢
空方強
那明天呢
不知道
就有可能下來了
好
就可能下去啊
如果每天多方強怎麼會下
怎麼會跌
他不會每天PK
跳探狗一樣
對啊
那這明天就危險了嘛
所以這個就是告訴你危險囉
是
今天有空方囉
昨天沒有多方 沒有空方嘛
今天有啦
但反過來
昨天空今天度
我可能要開心一下
對 如果每天都疊
今天多方轉牆了
那就是空方壓不下去了
那明天就可能上來
所以我們分辨了多空
再跟昨天比
然後去研判明天的可能走勢
那我們看一下就知道了
我們來用圖來舉例了
黑的...
蛙 多方牆
出現一個紅K了
多方牆又把昨天的高點過了
所以他就開始長了
好 紅的...
這個小心喔
明天要是疊就會下來
紅的 第二天是黑的
往下疊它就會下來了
紅的往上去就轉牆
黑的往下來就轉弱
那我們這邊就最明顯了
連弓兩天大量
這個都紅的嘛
所以我講你這不要賣
明天還有高點
你看明天有沒有高點
雖然是黑K
但其實它盤中有高點
那這個高點就告訴你
今天是空方來了
對不對 那空方來明天
就有可能要跌了
所以你要注意明天
那明天你就看他跌
後面你就賣了嘛
所以這邊就跟你沒關係
這就可以賣在相對的高點
否則你就捨不得賣
捨不得賣 捨不得賣
你就一直被套 就會被套牢
這個就是我們用K線看轉折
看這個轉折
那我們再放一張就更清楚了
收盤價 我們看收盤嘛
這個叫做收盤的K棒突破
或是跌破昨天的高點點
收盤突破昨天的高點
轉牆
突破了 它變轉牆囉
它比昨天的高點更高
昨天的最高點
收盤跌破昨天的最低點 轉弱
收盤突破昨天的最高點 轉牆
這個黑K收盤沒有跌破低點
所以還沒有轉弱
所以這邊是黑K
可他跟前一天的低點比
他還是收在比昨天的低點高
昨天的低點是多方的防守
你還沒有把它跌破
所以還是多
還有多方守在這
那等到你這個防守被跌破
他就殺了
他就很容易跌下來
所以跟前一天比
知道明天的狀況
這就是我們K線
看轉折的最重要
好 那我們就把一些
比較容易變的
好 這邊是常見的變盤線的長相
長相 長這樣要留意囉
除了那個紅KKK實體棒
只要你這個引線太長的
都小心一點
也有長的這種有點畸形的
沒有 叫它實體棒很少的
對 這個是沒有實體棒
沒有實體棒
代表開盤收盤是同一個價錢
但是盤中留了一個上限
開一盤收一盤就沒有價差
沒有價差就有一條線
但是盤中有供到很高
但對不起又被打回來了
所以它會是一個這樣的線線
對 一個山
好 那這些都是很奇怪的線
我們要把名字記起來嗎
還是把形狀記起來就好
把形狀記起來就好
什麼長梯線 紡垂線 十字線
除非你要教書啦
但是記形狀比較快
對 就是有長上引線
長下引線都很小心
都要小心
或者十里棒很小
上引線 下引線
這個叫十字線
那這些如果在高檔
在高檔你要擔心一下
如果這些圖形出現在高檔
要擔心 可能要下跌了
那如果在低檔
這個是指跌的訊號
那就是變盤嘛
他可能要變
朱老師講一個很重要
他沒有好壞的差別 沒有
他是變盤 完全在位置
位置低 可能變高
可能就往上漲
位置高就可能往下跌
他是個訊號
那我們剛剛有講
不一定會跌
所以你要準備明天
要準備好明天你的動作
萬一點你就要開始處理你的股票
或者是你要做長做短
你自己就去考慮好
可是這邊我就有一個疑問了
我怎麼知道什麼算低檔什麼算高檔
好 那等一下我們會特別的解釋
我這邊這幾個變盤線
我出現了變盤線
抓幾個範例給你看
你看這是不是十字變盤線
沒錯
這也是仿錘線
那我們都講不一定會變
那你怎麼知道會變
我不知道啊
剛才才有講
高檔跟低檔
可是我不知道
現在算高檔還低檔嗎
第二天要疊
我知道 第二天要疊
破前一天的第一點嘛
對不對
你怎麼知道第二天會疊
我怎麼知道
他有轉折線出現
我就要小心啊
因為第二天開低盤
開低就知道他要疊了
那是主力開的
剛才又講
開盤就知道了
所以你有了變盤線
你要注意第二天的開盤
有變盤線
第二天開低
可能就是
要看怎麼開
危險了 對不對
他可能就下來
那開高可能就還好
那趙華剛剛講這也是啊
對啊 這一根也是啊
那第二天開什麼
有點類似木碑線或什麼
是直線
可是第二天開高呢
所以就不會啦
那就不會變啦
所以開凡價剛剛講
為什麼那麼重要
因為開凡是主力
主力第二天開高
他還不太想跌啊
所以變盤線出現
也要看隔天主力的表態
主力的表態
好 所以在這個地方又有了
導錘變盤線
然後一開低
這個就開太低了
當然就下來
然後後面就疊了
對不對
那反彈上來
這裡又出現變盤線
那第二天又可以收盤疊破
所以開盤架就可以知道主力的企圖
這叫關鍵位置
所以有變盤線不一定會變
但是變的地方就一定有變盤線
有變盤線不一定會變
變的地方就一定有變盤線
所以看到變盤線就請你小心
還是要注意
要小心
不一定會變
可是只要變就有它
換句話講
大家現在應該有個認知了
我看到變盤線沒變
你放心
下次一定還會有變盤線
它才會變
那如果沒有
就不會變了
真的嗎
你就爆
百分之一百
沒有變
沒有變心
人總會跑
對不對
所以一定要知道說
有變盤線沒有變
你就放心了
那下次還會有 你就要小心喔
但是沒變盤線 我就繼續報
對 你就繼續報
他就不會別
K線就是在看高點 低點 轉折的
但是跟趨勢是兩回事
所以我在這裡你特別強調
這兩個要配合一起看
要一起看
在趨勢中來看轉折
看轉折不要忘了趨勢
你不要一直在看K線
今天又是紅色
今天又長了
要不要買 妳趨勢不是多
妳把趨勢忘了
我把趨勢忘了 對
趨勢不能忘 對
那這是多頭趨勢 對不對
底部嘛 底底高頭頭高
那這是頭頭低 底底底
這是空頭 好
所以從多到空 這個叫趨勢
那一個趨勢裡面
一定會漲跌 對
這個漲跌 漲跌就叫轉折
那這個轉折怎麼抓呢
就抓K線 好 剛剛有教了
所以K線在抓轉折的
所以我今天看K線
回後買上漲
那你不要忘了
這個趨勢是多嘛
對 OK 我就買了
那我這你啊
轉折要疊囉 我賣掉了
你不要忘了
這個頭沒有過
這不是多頭了
不要下次看到紅K
又以為可以賣
你又去買了
這邊的紅K就不能買了
因為你的趨勢已經變了
所以老師在這一段
是多頭趨勢的時候
去看 如果它有黑K的轉折
我不一定要賣掉
那你就在做趨勢了
你這邊在做趨勢
那你這邊就要賣了
因為趨勢變空了嘛
所以你這邊就一定要賣
但是等一下我也會請教老師
因為這跟我做的長短有關對不對
要是我做很短
我可能轉折我就賣啦
我如果做趨勢
我做長波段
我轉折我不見得要賣
你就抱趨勢
一直抱到空頭確認
所以我們做轉折次座短線
做趨勢叫長線
如果你在日線做趨勢
你就在日線做長線
老師治理名言
沒錯
所以也有大家也聽過一句話
長線保護短線
對 長線保護短線
那趨勢比較長嘛
所以你在趨勢裡面做轉折
趨勢會保護這個轉折
趨勢在保護這個轉折
也就是你在順次操作
老師 但是K棒聽說
因為你剛剛有講要跟前一天比
所以跟前一天比的
兩根K棒的組合
往往會決定它接下來是長
還是疊對不對
那所謂的兩根K棒的組合
我們剛剛有講是一根
這是一根嘛
那兩根就是你跟昨天一起看
那就叫兩根
那最長出現的
而且轉折機率已經80% 90%
80% 90% 而且注意囉
三個會長的K棒組合
大家趕快來學喔
但我還是強調會長不一定能做
會長不一定能 因為要看趨勢對不對
我學到了 剛剛講的話不要忘了
我會長 如果是反彈
那就是空頭回補
因為他會長了嘛
他會長 但是就是你空單補掉而已
不是要做多 把它補掉
好 這個是最嚴重的
最嚴重
因為這個幾乎已經
這個確認了嘛
我們是會長啦
會長的嚴重我接受
最嚴重的轉折啦
就是說你空單一定要補了
為什麼 第一個有大量
第二個紅K 收盤把KK吃掉
收盤整個把檢驗的AK吃掉
這叫做長紅吞噬
對 這個你空單一定要補了
如果手上空單一定要補
多單看趨勢
那我們剛剛有一講說嘛
收盤過了昨天的高點
就轉強了嘛
所以你空單不補
明天再漲你就少賺了
你就更少賺了
這樣對不對
那這個是我們剛剛講的長下影線
所以這個叫變盤線
變盤線出現囉
你就明天不要開高
這種明天開高盤
你的空彈要補
那如果這個位置又疊得很深了
這裡又有支撐了
這裡又爆亮了
那明天大概八九成都會上來
所以我就來做多囉
你的策略上可以做一個策略的
比如說我空了十張
那我就先補五張
因為他還沒有過昨天的高點
他還沒有過昨天的高點
但是向上的訊號很明確
就說很強了
那你就先補個五張
那明天開高就全部補
如果再開高就全部補
老師現在提醒我們的是
因為他會漲
但是因為還要確認位置嗎
位置 多頭回檔黑K
看到紅K你就準備做了
就準備進場做多
這樣子這三個是在第一檔
最常見的轉折的訊號
這個就是他的紅K跟黑K
是一樣的 對不對
這是最常見的
最常見的轉折
那我們就抓個例子
給他看一下就好了
每天疊 每天疊
我剛剛有講 黑的黑的你就爆吧
你就爆
空單就爆啦
紅的來了 你就不能說不理他囉
你一不理就跑到這邊
這邊空單要回補
多單可以進場嗎
對 多單叫強反彈
強反彈喔
我們有專門的條件
專門的條件
那我們有一集再來講
對
那個條件合你就可以去搶
好不好
那我們就先講最基本的
空頭要回補
因為這叫吞式
吞式 超過吞式
補完了後面他就會轉成多
這叫趨勢
是
趨勢已經成型了
後面你就開始做多了
就用做多了 好不好
朱老師常常強調趨勢
如果你看到那樣K-Bang組合
只是說他可能要反彈
所以空單要回補
可是你要不要做多
你要多頭趨勢出來
要多頭趨勢
那這是我們剛才第二個長相一些
對
空單可以補一半
明天上來了你就全部
上來他支撐很強
對
你看連著兩天都下雨線
那再 你看又是不是開高
對 又開高 主力來了
所以今天各位看完了
就要注意開盤價
開盤價很重要 主力的定調
你看他就會開高 對不對
所以你就知道
你看這個黑黑第二天開低
就還會跌
因為他還是又開低
剛剛那講的是
三根可能反彈或會長的
可是現在是不是會有三種
是會跌的
會下跌的
會下跌的K棒組合
代表多單
我可能要獲利了解
對 大部分都做多嘛
所以做多的高檔
這個叫長黑吞噬
如果有爆亮
這個就請你出場
反過來
剛剛長紅吞噬
現在長黑吞噬
那就多單出場
因為這叫確認
轉折確認
轉折確認當然就很容易跌
那如果看到長上領械
你可以先出一半
如果因為有爆量嘛
所以這個地方基本上
盤中拉上來就很多人在賣
所以才會打下來的
但是他還沒有破前一天的低點
所以就賣一半就好了
那明天不要開低喔
主力開低就慘了
反正技術分析就像
我常跟同學講
你來上我課就是來聽我練金
我就每天練給你聽
高檔爆量這個你就賣一半
明天開低你就全跑
如果你聽懂了
下次你就照做
他們可能頭會有點痛
像那個孫悟空被帶了那個
緊咕咒
因為你練久了
就變成自然動作
為什麼如果你沒有印象深刻
你一定會考慮太多
考慮太多
結果你就捨不得賣
捨不得賣就越套越深
那這個就是變藍的意思
紅的配黑的
那這個我要特別說明
這一組K線最在
哪裡最容易發現
就是假突破
假突破的時候
最容易有這樣子的K線
也就是反整突破紅K
是不是要進場
要啊
那第二天就來了
糟糕 假突破
這就假突破
你要趕快做好
你的一些準備了
因為騙線
我們這個就叫騙線
因為在股票社長沒有百分之百
有些主力就很壞
他就喜歡騙你
那騙了我進去啦
那可是你第二天
就告訴我這是假的
所以你就趕快走
大概二分之一跌破
大概就假的
就假的
也不要練戰對不對
再加上有大量
有大量
因為這時候你沒有陪多少
等到你明天整個殺下來
你就很容易就被套了
所以這個最容易在
假突破的地方看到
這個提醒很重要喔
這一組線
而且不要練戰
沒錯
我們講賺錢可以報啦
賠錢不要報
賠錢越報越賠
這根長黑吹勢就很明顯
非常明顯
你看你從這裡你回後買上榨
假設你每天抱
好不容易抱到這
哇這一根前逆趕快走
可是這一根好痛
這一根把五日十日一次跌破
沒錯 我可能獲利整個吐回去
少了三分之一或二分之一
我一定要在這天賣嗎
那你就在這天賣
這個我剛剛有講個概念
你回去找一百張圖
上面有長黑吞噬爆亮的
你去看一百張後面的結果
你就相信
八九不離十
都是八八八八八就下去了
這就叫相信技術分析
因為技術分析
百分之九十九這個都會跌
你可能運氣好
有一張沒跌對不對
但是你要找一百張
所以你就會相信
九十張都會跌
所以我還是賣了
所以不要留戀
對 你就賣掉了
好 那這個就更嚴重了
這一張圖我們先不看後面
所以這個地方叫你賣囉
叫我賣 好
賣掉了
賣掉了這個叫多頭的回檔
所以先把趨勢弄清楚
有了轉折不要忘的趨勢
所以這叫多頭回檔
那回檔以後
但他已經灌破前一天的
就回檔了
那現在回檔還在跌
所以你不可能買
這還是KK
然後你再來看
還是黑的
所以你不會買
然後來
紅K
有了
這個叫回後買上漲
然後把公K第一點停損守好
然後你再來
哇 賺錢了
然後要過上面的
左邊那個壓力了
哎呦
要不要跑
跑
對啊 跑了
看到轉折不要忘了
你的趨勢變了
因為你錢高沒過
這是回後買上漲
要過錢高嘛
所以 而且他一個長黑吞噬啊
剛才已經告訴你了嘛
長黑吞噬就賣嘛
你就賣
不要留戀啊對不對
如果你不留戀
第二天空頭了
對 從此就沒有這個高點
這邊逃不了的話
這邊繳更麻
你不會賣了啦
理論上就不會賣了
你這你都捨不得砍
這邊會捨不得砍
就庫上古了啦
所以這種圖很容易就看到的
來 有囉 漲兩天
紅的配黑
再來考我們好了
老師你可以考考網友
網友喜歡被考
但是知道有沒有學會啊
對不對
要不要賣
這一個嗎 紅的配黑的
這個看起來是老師說要賣的
對 尤其是容易出現在假突破
如果你要 亂講一通
因為如果你不賣的話
就是明天不能怎樣
開低 沒錯
明天開低 開低了
趕快跑啊 跑吧
跑掉了嘛
這叫多頭回檔 對
回後買上漲 對
然後要過前高 好
前面高點在哪裡 長黑尊世
那個就前面的高點 對
這邊要過嘛
其實要過這個
好
長黑的高點
好 繼續看
可以爆
過啦
這叫什麼
這叫
這叫變盤械
可是它過了
變盤械就有可能變
所以明天也不一定會疊
我要看它開盤
這要變盤械
長上影械
小心點喔
兩天變盤械
開什麼 不行的 開低了
開地就要下來了
教練嘛
OK 我覺得老師上課一定就這樣子
所以大家學得很快
這個剛才這個遮圖
在我開課叫做走圖
走圖
走圖班
是
走圖就很厲害了
因為每根K線都要解釋
是
不是只有這個轉折
這根這根
你每根都要解釋
所以我們理財達人秀的觀眾
非常有福氣
老師帶著我們剛剛一個走圖
走圖是進階型的課程
對 這樣子你就很清楚了
所以你看到訊號後面會疊
看到這個後面會疊
下次就不要被他騙
老師他有就是
剛剛講說時間
我們不是用時間來決定長線短線
但是如果日K 週K 月K
也是會有網友反應說
我要怎麼判斷我要看哪個K
好 我們先有個概念
日線K線是短的 短線的
所以我們剛剛在走都是日線
是短線的
那周線是中期的
那為什麼
因為周線是一個禮拜交易的結果
所以今天禮拜三
所以周線還沒收
還沒出現
我們日線已經收了
周線還沒抽
那如果明後天又大跌
可能周線又變黑的了
對不對
所以周線是一個禮拜
月線就不用講了
是一個月的
所以如果你是做中長期的
你就要去看周線跟月線
變盤械
假如這一週收個黑K
週限收黑K
那下週是不是很容易就跌了
用剛才的理念
只是換成週
換到週限去看
週限漲了五週了
那這一週收黑K了
或者常上一線了
那下週禮拜一就不能開低盤
禮拜一是週的開盤
那一開低
很可能週限就要回檔
所以我們的開盤
變成禮拜一的開盤
是週限的開盤
所以我們如果看中長線的人
就看周線有沒有變化
對
周線都沒變化 都是紅K
那你在日線就做多嘛
就一直做就好了
因為周線沒有變化
但是周線要回檔
你日線就不能做了
日線要退出
因為周線一回檔就一個禮拜
那你日線怎麼賺
跌一個禮拜
所以日線要退
做多的要退
這個就是說
我們做短線要配合看長線
長線沒有變化
它會保護短線
長線會保護短線
均線也是這個概念
月線保護周線
周線保護日線
我們今天講了非常完整的K棒
對不對
趙華也把K棒再學了一次
我覺得今天的K棒
真的講得非常清楚
但是K棒還有一個
進階型的密技是什麼呢
就是它的位置
但這個位置要怎麼看
我們會在精英班教你看
K棒的位置
然後來抓到最正確的買賣點
在這邊的話趙華趙 慣例要告訴你
我注意到你囉
謝謝你加入我們的精英班
而且給我們很多的鼓勵喔
我們來看這個叫做WIN
哇 你的名字很棒
就叫做WIN
他說看完才知道
為什麼之前老師買在高點
真的收穫很多要謝謝朱老師
然後這個是蘇的
這個是女孩子喔
他說趙華很棒 謝謝你喔
他說一直都很崇拜朱老師
你就說我都買齊了
謝謝
老師你的思路很清晰喔
聽你講股票就會覺得
操作變簡單了
這就是我們理財大人秀的初衷
希望你覺得操作不是那麼難喔
然後這個是Vince
他說我是來自馬來西亞的
朱老師 你的鐵粉
很多是亞洲區域的
好喜歡朱老師的教學
受益肥淺感謝趙華老師
和節目組的用心
那趙華也謝謝馬來西亞的
好朋友囉
好 那今天的標古在線等
K棒大全集喔
相信你一定跟趙華一樣
收穫非常的多喔
K棒他在趨勢中看轉折
今天朱老師整場就在強調這件事情
所以你看轉折要搭配趨勢
還有就是今天的K-BANG搭配昨天的K-BANG
你會知道明天的K-BANG這樣怎樣
盤前的工作你要做足
希望今天的標普再見
等你離台單就對你有幫助
我們下次再見了
拜拜
字幕製作人Zither Harp